they want me to get to the music video
you people kept my iPad from me for over
a week and now you say get to the music
video fine I'll get to the music video
what song is it this is by Ariana Grande
and Ethan Slater and I've been told that
a woman is going to explain this to me
as the song goes on is that correct Mr
Davies that is correct is that woman
marel young marel yeah young marel okay
CU I they gave me it's like a it's like
a memoir here they gave me this whole
timeline of AR on Grande and this guy so
uh take it away marel you can explain it
as it goes
on oh yeah real exclusive typical Ari
you know I think I liked it better when
her ponytail was a few centimeters
higher right and I mean who car if she's
happy I don't want happy I want
art I miss the old Ari you know the
singer you don't say I hear she's
starting her own AR inal hummus line
next oh my god did she really do that
well I read it on the internet so it
must be true well it must
[Music]
be
all right I kind of like
[Music]
it the 70 is kind of funky you
no when
everybody
died and healing from
somebody or something we don't see just
right Bo come on put your liptick
on boy put your it's like everything's
got to be gay now boy put your
liptick dark situation just s on your
leg and
be
yes
and with your
chest and
[Music]
be when I'm done with caring what you
think no I won't
hide like the message is obviously just
evil and Bal cuz it's just you know
don't yuck my yum Be authentically You
by conforming to all of the most fattish
views and behaviors of 2024
but I kind of like the music it's kind
of kind of fun kind of
funky like it's obviously super gay like
everything has to be in 2024 but
whatever I don't know like you can't I
just I take that as the starting point
so if you take all the
ideology and the even the way she's
singing is in this
very Millennial Zoomer way of like uh
there's not even like much air
underneath my voice like you know it's
like whatever I'm apathetic I'll just do
what I want man and I'm we're all
lesbians or whatever you know it's like
okay fine that's the starting point is
it is it good on top of that yes yeah it
is don't com on my body to
not business is yours mine is
mine why do you care so much who's that
right
[Music]
why pretty good
dancer
it's funny the irony is she says say
that from your chest but she is not
her voice is in almost like a gladle fry
and what she's saying is totally
apathetic she's not you know to speak
from your chest is to speak with
conviction she said she doesn't have
convictions she goes just do whatever
you want and don't think anything's
subjectively true and just kind of do
whatever like feels kind of good or
whatever doesn't feel too
bad you know so her her behavior and the
rest of the lyrics undercut the thesis
of the song which is funny and I think
probably unintentional because that's
just all of modern liberalism you know
liberalism it has been said is an
ideology uh where one cannot even take
one's own side in an argument you know
uh and and it's just this kind of
radical subjectivism and skepticism and
but they think they're they're really
you know convicted they're convicted
about not having convictions as she is
but I don't know I kind of the music's
okay my bar is so low these days I could
kind of you know could dance to it do
you know what she was singing
about just kind of liberalism right Mr
DAV is asking what she was singing about
what's she singing I'll let marel give
you the skinny okay marel give me the
story what's up okay Michael so Ariana
Grande was cast as Glend of the Good by
the way can the people hear this or
you're just telling me I'm I'm the
people can hear me okay good okay so
Ariana Grande was cast as Glend of the
good witch in the new Wicked movie
that's going to come out this year and
she befriended her co-star Ethan Slater
who when they met was married to his
high school sweetheart and had a newborn
baby yeah so she became friends with his
family she actually held their baby met
their family members and then Ethan
Slater had an affair with an affair with
Ariana Grande and after they were seen
in public kissing instead of trying to
redeem his marriage and returning to his
wife and infant actually left his wife
and child and he divorced um and is now
with Ariana Grande so in August after
they took their relationship in the open
the public pointed out that she's a home
wrecker and stole a husband and a father
and her response to the criticism is
this
song that sounds that sounds about
right is he a what is this line about
boy come put your lipstick on to my
knowledge he's not but there's a photo
circulating of him uh wearing baby
clothes a diaper holding a baby bottle
so it's actually unsure like in a in a
performance or in like that's just on a
Friday night or something I think it's
just a photo it it's not performance
related to my
knowledge oh no oh no that's bad I had
heard about this I don't know who Ethan
Slater is but I Alisa saw it pop up on
Instagram she said max did you hear what
happened with every I was like I
certainly did not no Candace Owens he's
an unfortunate looking person oh is he
interesting I I certainly couldn't I
could barely pick her out of a lineup
and so they were the high school
sweethearts right Ethan and his
wife and then man what a what a dummy
what a dummy can you like what in what
way does his life improve doing that in
every way his life gets
worse even if you think Ariana Grande is
kind of hot or something first of all
that'll last what five minutes and then
and I don't know she's in Show Business
and she's like you know I can't imagine
that that's an easy life to to live with
that kind of a person so what do you do
you give up your kid you give up your
wife you give up your whole life you
give up your reputation you give up any
claim to Virtue you get for
like what for what so that you can be
the subject of a very mediocre modern
song Oh pathetic
pathetic but I I blame him more than I
blame her
she's a wacko Showbiz girl you know what
do you expect of course she's going to
do that stuff this guy
though you're you're a man you're
supposed to be a man and defend your
family you can't defend your family for
5 seconds in front of a girl who's what
5 feet tall and 100 pounds dripping wet
good grief pathetic man that was a great
clip wasn't it now make sure that you
ring the bell subscribe to the Michael
NS YouTube channel and we'll see you
next time